it's july 6th of 2014. okay
i see
who's going to eventually become my the
mother of my two beautiful children wow
and so when i saw her dude never forget
i saw i was drinking strawberry vodka
having fun i was probably you know on an
app looking for domino's pizza i'm
always anytime i drink even though new
york city has the best italian food
every time i drink i always want pizza
hut and dominos i think it's just pain
it's just a cycle of pain it's like i
want to look in the mirror and be like
you [ __ ] suck you eat that domino's
[ __ ] oh yeah something like that like
bdsm yeah it's like like a suicidal
thing you know yeah like italian bdsm
yes yes so i say i see her i see her and
she's like dancing and it was one of
those things where it was like almost
like in a movie where i was like like
truthfully i was like my heart like
stopped like i was like like it's the
only time i ever felt that in my life
where i looked at her and i was like
oh my god like like the beauty was like
like floored and again like i said i was
i i said everything before i had you
know we're talking to beautiful women
and ben so she was beautiful like you
know there were other girls but there
was something different about her and i
said to my boy patty patty fly balls who
i never he was chewing on a straw and i
said to him i'd do that yeah i said to
him i said um i said dude look at how
beautiful that woman is and she he was
like i know she's amazing and i was like
he he agreed he agreed and i was like i
was excited i said that i said
i said that literally is the hottest
girl i've ever seen in my life i was
like i can't even think right now and he
was like oh and he was like bro relax
what'd you do then you left no so he
goes he goes dude yeah she's a smoking
hot puerto rican check like i get it
like
and i said i got to go up and talk to
her
i said i literally was like inside of me
i was like if i do not talk to her like
this is gonna bother me for the rest of
my [ __ ] life like i'm never gonna
forget this woman so i go up to her and
i say listen i said i you know i saw you
from across was the music loud was it
hard to get her attention
that part i don't remember because i was
enamored because you know what's amazing
about her she was so beautiful and
obviously is so beautiful but the thing
is what i focus on is she has a chipped
tooth so i was looking at her chipped
tooth because i was like wow
you know you're like from afar like you
don't notice you have a chip tooth but
then when i get closer it's almost like
the chip tooth it even made it more
beautiful because it's like it's unique
it's almost like a like a hot chick with
a scar you know what i mean like i was
like i like this this is yeah it's
almost like you gotta buy a vowel or
something yeah like one of the most
beautiful women i've ever met besides
her has no pinkies and i was like and
she's a smoke show but she's got no
pinkies and she hides them but she's you
don't meet people that don't have
pinkies yeah and she doesn't have them
but she's gorgeous wow she's almost like
a sloth almost yes she's dude i'll tell
you this first girl i ever kissed had a
chipped tooth yep
yep and they made us kiss we were in
love man i don't know if we were in love
but we live near each other
well sometimes that's all it takes
that's what being in love was and being
married was in ancient times you just
knew the people in your village that's
why this whole concept of a soulmate you
there's nine billion people in this
world and we're all connected through
mark zuckerberg the god yeah so it's
like you this whole idea of a soul mate
and a one and only that's that's ancient
tribe [ __ ] this is not new world
thinking because new we're all connected
man you just you knew about 15 people
right back in the day right so you know
what i mean
so kind of with her with jasmine
i walked up to her and i said i said i
it's it's i can't stop
like looking at you guys wow i said do
you have a boyfriend full psychopath
with the first time i can't stop looking
at you yeah
[Laughter]
you should have had somebody write it on
your back with a marker and just pull
your shirt up yeah i went full psycho
because i was just so and i just love
brother that's what i'm telling you
that's love yeah and i said to her i
said is there any way i could just buy
you a drink and she said you could but
my boyfriend is here
so then i was like whoa because i got a
rule man if you got a boyfriend i don't
mess with that right or a husband like i
don't i think that's bad karma i would
never want that i don't mess with that
like there's plenty of fish in the sea
but something about her i was like
i almost feel like it doesn't matter
like i don't care that you know like i
almost have to be like i don't care at
all that you have a boyfriend
yeah i have to take a chance even if
this guy kills me because i'm sure based
off what you look like you probably have
like some guido like convict
murderer brooklyn italian boyfriend
which i was right volleyball playing too
yup
uh my stepdad found out that some lady
was getting married that he used to have
a huge crush on
and he went over he was at a bar or
something that night he found out she's
got engaged and he drove over to the
house
and went up on her porch like in the
middle of the night
and said look i got all these feelings
for you and blah blah blah and she
didn't care right and while he was up
there somebody burned his car in the
front of the street
literally his car is burning which is a
horrible look if you're trying to tell
somebody like that you're the guy for
them you know it's just like oh my god
and then you come back with a bicycle
yeah no way dude you're not the guy had
your car set on fire yeah i don't know
what happened i i either he just left a
cigarette in the diaz or something that
happened you know yeah so
you know she says i got a boyfriend and
i said i can't i won't be deterred not
on this one so i said you know what i'm
i'm just gonna have to stick around and
fight this out and and for like an hour
i would you know kept drinking and i was
just like you know what man like i gotta
and i know she was talking to the
bartender and so the bartender was
turned out to be one of her close
friends still is one of her close
friends and so i said to the bartender i
said what what is it going to what is it
going to take for me what is it going to
take for me to get this your friend to
like look at me and notice me i was like
does she really have a boyfriend and she
was like i can't answer that and i was
like oh so they're playing history she
might not have a boyfriend what's it
called a misdirect
no i think it's called like a um turn of
events a turn of events
so
she says i i can't i i can't answer that
i said well what's it gonna take and she
was like she's she's she loves dancing
she's like and she's puerto rican like
you gotta come up with some type of yeah
they love dancing like you gotta dance
like do you know how to do bachata and i
said
i'm gonna try yeah so i googled bachata
and i told them i told because she had
the music you know she's a bartender i
said let me go let me let me look at
some [ __ ] let me youtube a couple of
youtube some stuff
and so i said and my boy was like yo
dude remember that scene and along came
polly when ben stiller started dancing
spanish and that's how he got
his woman
so we watched that scene and i played
that song from that movie oh yes so i
played that song and i'm like i'm just
going to come up to her and dance with
her and then ah bro this is freaking
getting good yeah dude so she said so
she so so the bartender was like i'm
gonna play that song for you and you
come up with those dance moves no were
you scared yeah brother's madness you
could go outside and warm up or do you
just warm up right i was drinking so i
was like having fun with it you know i
was like whatever dude this is going to
be great yeah and you got nothing to
lose because you're sitting there with a
drinking with an irish man yeah dude a
couple of irishmen actually
yeah so i start so they they play that
song nothing's further from them being
happily married and sitting somewhere
with two irish dudes
yeah dude that is the complete opposite
of it yeah
so so oh dude and uh two irish men and
with uh listening to the mets games with
the headphones
you know like they were watching the
mets get like they were trying to get
the met score yeah and and and so i just
did that i did that dance play that song
she kind of giggled and she goes and she
goes that was a nice attempt she goes
that was a nice attempt and she goes how
about this i'll tell you my name so she
tells me her name and i was like okay
and she goes and then what i almost it
almost was like it was a setup but i
swear to god it wasn't i had been on a
show on mtv called guy code and girl
code which is relatively still popular
yeah um
and all those guys
guys and girls so so i um i i
uh
somebody came up to me and wanted a
picture with me from that show and then
she was like why do they want a picture
with you and i was like oh i'm on a show
on on it's on mtv and she was like how
old are you i was like 30. and she was
like you still aren't watching mtv and i
was like no i'm not watching it i'm just
on the show yeah yeah that's just uh
that's just that's fine man you're not a
bad guy that's just a business choice i
was like i said i was like i you know i
needed i i'm just i'm working yeah i'm
working she said that the puerto rican
yeah she said that to me she was like
what do you want right and that so i
said um they trust a lot of television
puerto ricans are more
they're more
real life yes yeah like if i was working
at a gas station or something like that
she'd be more like this is my kind of
guy right but so she was like okay and
then she said um she said what's the
show and i told her and she goes all
right maybe i'll look it up one day and
i was like okay well that could take
forever dude she's so vague doesn't it
no we only have a lifetime i know dude
so then she goes so then she goes um she
was like [ __ ] with me so she goes um
she goes all right she goes look at this
hold on she goes i'm leaving
she goes i gotta i gotta get home she
goes i gotta get home to my son oh so
that was so when she said that got the s
bomb she dropped the s bomb so in my
heart
my heart yeah i gotta get home to my
chlamydia yeah
i said i said
if you get i said cause already then i
said okay i said well the first thing i
said i said uh is that you have a son
with your boyfriend she goes no and i
said is she so is the is the sun's
father around us or does he is he
deceased and she was like why would you
want him to be deceased i was like i
don't i was just i was just hoping that
he was so i could step in and be a step
dad like i just said that immediately
and she was like you're like crazy and i
was like yeah and she was like and she
was like he's still in the picture i was
like okay so but when she said that to
me i already felt inferior to him so i
said to myself in my heart and head at
that moment i said the first time i have
sex with this woman i'm not pulling out
i need to get her pregnant too to even
the playing field that's how nuts i was
you went full puerto rican and that's
eventually what i did fyi no way yeah
i met her i met her i met her in august
of 2014. we conceived
july of 2014 my daughter delilah was
conceived in august i have a six and a
half two fourteen yeah dude wow my
daughter was born in may of 2015. wow so
so so you purposely impregnated her 1
wow
because i felt so inferior to this guy i
didn't even know and i was like this is
the woman of my dreams i'm gonna play
hardball i need this he's got one on the
board i'm gonna get one of them i said
yeah i'm and now i got two on the board
now i got a second kid so now i'm like
two to one [ __ ] so it's
psychotic that's how i live my life yeah
so so i i kind of like this yeah dude i
went all in because everyone was like
you're crazy and i was like i feel like
i'm going to uberx with no breaks yeah
dude i was like yeah maybe i am yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you